Northern Virginia's leading homebuilder, hotel operator, and apartment manager delivering unmatched service and quality living.
With 22 properties and over 5,500 units across Arlington, Alexandria, and St. Louis,
Dittmar offers a variety of housing options with easy access to transportation.
Visit rentsdittmar.com to learn more, because where you live matters.
I know when we were playing, you were in the company.
I want to start going to the company.
You were in the company.
Don't use it! Don't use it!
You finished like a two and a half years out.
And we really wanted to get up to the level you set us.
I literally said I was going to give you the outfit.
That's what I'm excited to say.
You're doing the whole thing?
I think so.
As long as you're practicing.
You have to do that.
If I'm practicing, all the way up to the end of the day, I'm going to have to do that.
You literally were going to do that.
Oh, that's...
It was super fun.
I'm going to make it this way.